Dos hombres empezaron a operar con Bitcoin exactamente el mismo día.
Uno pasó 12 horas al día pegado a los gráficos,
persiguiendo cada vela verde con desesperación.
Pero anoche, una sola "trampa de ballena"
liquidó por completo los ahorros de toda su vida.
¿Y el otro hombre? Él disfrutó de una cena con su familia,
durmió tranquilo y despertó con una ganancia de 5,000 dólares.
La diferencia no fue suerte. Fue el sistema.
Uno fue la "presa", el otro se convirtió en un "ganador".
La mayoría falla porque juega al juego de las ballenas.
Ellos compran cuando se les ordena comprar,
pero cuando hay una trampa, tú eres solo el alimento.
Trap Defence BTC cambia las reglas
al visualizar lo invisible en el mercado.
Nuestro motor detecta la manipulación institucional
antes de que golpee tu bolsillo con fuerza.
Te damos la habilidad definitiva: la disciplina
para proteger tu capital hasta que el éxito sea inevitable.
Es una estrategia de supervivencia de alta precisión
para un mercado de alto riesgo.
Y hoy, puedes equiparte sin costo alguno.
Únete a la Academy ahora y obtén gratis
la "Minimum Edition" del Trap Score.
Sin tarjetas, sin engaños.
Solo la cruda realidad del mercado frente a ti.
Deja de ser la presa, es hora de ser el cazador.
Haz clic abajo para activar el bot
y reclama tu acceso gratuito ahora mismo.
Empieza hoy.
Accede aquí.